that's something i
often think about because we're just
reading books about these people
i think about with like jeffrey epstein
for example oh yeah
like evil people not evil but people
have done evil things
let's not go to the dan carl and they go
people that do evil things i wonder what
they're like in a room because i know
quite a lot of
intelligent people that were
did not see uh did not see the evil in
jeffrey epstein
and spend time with him and not were not
bothered by in the same sense
hitler it seems like he was able to
get just even on before he would have
power
because people get intoxicated by power
and so on they want to be close to power
but even before he had power he was able
to convince people
and it's unclear like is there something
that's more than words it's like the way
you i mean that people talk tell stories
about like this piercing
look or whatever all that kind of stuff
i i wonder if that
if that's somehow a part of it like that
has to be the base floor
of any of these charismatic leaders you
have to be able to in a room
alone be able to convince anybody of
anything
you